robert spencer a gay man from
afghanistan who was burned by a taliban
member said he was
shocked by the lack of support and
solidarity shown by the international
lgbt community
i don't get it maybe you can explain it
why in the world
has the lbgtq community adopted
protecting islam when under islam they
are subject to the death penalty for the
capital crime of being gay
well that's all covered up in america
today probably most of the lgbt
whatever people who uh come out against
islamophobia
they have no idea i can tell you that i
spoke at a university a few years back
and there was a young man in the
audience holding up a sign said queers
against islamophobia so i have actually
had a manual of islamic law with me and
i started reading out about how
homosexuals should be executed uh and so
on and so on and that this was based on
muhammad's teachings
and uh this muslim guy came over and
gave the man with the queers against
islamophobia sign a big hug and said
this is my best friend and the whole
place is cheering and and booing at me
and the point is that
these guys were basing their arguments
essentially on
anecdotal evidence that uh
this young man if he was really the
friend of the gay man which i actually
kind of doubt because he was dressed in
uh full traditional muslim guard uh
he he uh
was basing that on the personal
relationship that he had it doesn't
change what islamic law
says
and islamic law does say what it says
but there's so much deception out there
that these things are covered up and so
the gay community in the united states
for the most part thinks it's
islamophobic and we've had uh
all kinds of attacks on this basis by
standing up for the human rights of gays
in islamic countries a few years back
pamela geller and i put together an ad
campaign in san francisco that just
quoted islamic leaders
talking about how gays should be put to
death and we were denounced by the san
francisco
uh whatever it's called the it's not the
city council but it is the city council
by another name the board of examiners
or something anyway they uh denounced us
not the
muslim leaders that were in our ads but
they denounced us for being islamophobic
and this is the kind of disconnect that
there is
in this community that it seems as if
there's a resolute determination not to
face unpleasant realities